بالفعل هناك يعني مسائل كثيره او نقاط
كثيره يمكن تسليط الضوء عليها بالاضافه
الى محور زبروج الذي سننتقل اليه اولا
انخفاض وتيره القصف الاوكراني على مدينه
وضواحيها الى النصف تقريبا وهذا ما يشير
الى يعني نقصان الذخيره عند الجانب
الاوكراني حسب تصريحات الدفاع بانها تقصف
مستودعات الذخيره
والعتاد الاوكراني بشكل يومي ومستمر رغم
ذلك هناك اثر القصف الاوكراني للاربعه
وعشرين ساعه الماضيه قتيل وعدت اصابات هنا
في دانيت لكن القصف الروسي لكييف وعده مدن
اوكرانيه ربما يكون كاشاره من الكرملين
الروسي بعد تصريحات الرئيس الروسي يوم امس
فلاديمير بوتين ان روسيا لديها من الاسلحه
والذخيره
والصواريخ والاسلحه الثقيله فيها لاكمال
العمليه العسكريه حتى تحقيق اهدافها في
منطقه دمباس وفي المقاطعات التي ضمها
الاتحاد الروسي اليه هذا جانب اخر اما على
سبيل المعارك في الشرق الاوكراني هنا ما
زالت قوات فاجنر تطوق مدينه باخموت من
النواحي الثلاث اضافه الى يعني
تطويق اكثر من الناحيه الغربيه حسب ما قال
نائب زعيم الانفصاليين هنا دينيس بوشيم
بانهم قاموا قوسين او ادنى من قطع
الامدادات بشكل كامل حيث ان الطرق المؤديه
الى المقاتلين الاوكرانيين الذين يتمركزوا
في مدينه باقمت عبر طريقين طريق قسطنطين
اوفكا وقط وطريق
الطرق السريعه
والدفاع الروسيه اعلنت بانها سيطرت بالقصف
المدفعي على كل الامدادات التي تصل الى
الجيش الاوكراني من هذان الطريقان اذا
لابد ان جيش الاوكراني بات محاصرا او
سيحاصر ويصبح مقطوع عنه الذخيره
والامدادات العسكريه في الوقت القريب
الغربيه تحدثنا عن انا الربيع المقبل
سيشهد معارك هي الاعنف منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب هل من مؤشرات ميدانيه رائد تؤكد ما
جاء في هذه التقارير
سؤال في مكان واحمد لان الامدادات
العسكريه البشريه بالدرجه الاولى نشهد هنا
في شوارع يعني اعداد كبيره من الجنود
المقاتلين الذين وصلوا الى المنطقه ذلك
بعد اعلان التعبئه الجزئي الجزئيه في
موسكو من موسكو شهر سبتمبر العام الماضي
بعدها كانت فتره تدريب ومن ثم بدانا نشهد
حضور كبير وكثيف للاعداد البشريه المقصود
الجنود كما ان هناك ارتال عسكريه نشهدها
تتنقل من محور الى اخر في المنطقه بالفعل
هناك حضور قوي
يعني للجنود الروس كما ان هناك حضور لسلاح
الجو الروسي لم يكن سابقا يعني خلال العام
الماضي لم نشهد حضور قوي لسلاح الجو او
المقاتلات الروسيه في سماء المقطع المنطقه
اليوم نجد حضور كبير لهذه المقاتلات
بالفعل هناك يعني
في كل المحاور عدا عن المحور الشمالي حيث
بخمت هناك المحور الجنوبي مدينه غلادار
ايضا اعلنت السلطات هنا عن تطويق المدينه
من ثلاثه نواحي ايضا كانصف دائره ولكن
الحديث عن تحصينات متينه لدى الجيش
الاوكراني اضافه الى اليه عسكريه ثقيله
دبابات ومدافع لديهم وانهم محصنون بشكل
جيد وربما يطول مده الحصار وتطول مده
السيطره حسب التصريحات على هذه المدينه
شكرا